[Music]
dungeons when it comes to iconic and
traditional Zelda staples this is about
as classic as it gets these enemy
infested trap filled labyrinths are
right up there with the green tunic the
bow even Zelda and Ganon they were
present from the very beginning and made
their stay in the series all the way up
until breath the wild there is sort of a
debate on if the divine beast should
even be considered as dungeon since well
they're not really comparable to the
ones from the early titles and in terms
of size and complexity even outclassed
by some of the most basic dungeons from
the early games now I love breath the
wild and is right up there with some of
my favorite games of all time but if
there's one criticism that I do share
with other people it's the absence of
traditional dungeons
there's just something magical about
them and always one of the things I'm
looking forward to the most when booting
up a new installment
bref the wilds director Eiji Aonuma
stated that for sequel the team is
looking into new ideas and improvements
brought out by fans funnily enough even
directly mentioning the fact that people
want to be able to pet dogs and I
couldn't agree more with this large
incentive to bring back traditional
dungeons there is a good chance that the
word has reached the ears of the Zelda
team so let's imagine for a moment that
quote-unquote real dungeons will make a
comeback in the sequel the mechanics
introduced in breath the wild like
climbing and paragliding do not exactly
mix well with the old dungeon designs
from the previous games as their
challenge would be completely neglected
by Link's newfound mobility it's still
unclear if the sheikah slate will
actually make a return so I'm not taking
this mechanic into consideration until
we know more about the sequel but I
think it's safe to say that the
paraglider and climbing most definitely
will make a comeback especially since we
are revisiting the same Hyrule while
thinking what it actually means for a
dungeon to be successful I managed to
narrow down my criteria to a list of 5
dungeon mechanics and items complexity
and or survival aesthetics and
atmosphere which also includes music
enemies and bosses and size and scope so
let's start from the
and just work our way down starting with
dungeon mechanics and items oh and here
to help me with this analysis is
Nintendo black crisis
what would a traditional dungeon in
breadth of the wild to look like
as stated before completely going back
to the old formula is likely not going
to work a room like this would be a
cakewalk for breadth of the wilds link
given the fact that he is much more
mobile than his past iterations unless
of course they take away these tools
once you enter the dungeon removing the
paraglider for example similar to how
mario sunshine removes flood from the
equation when entering certain
platforming levels but this option isn't
preferred as it's a huge missed
opportunity to create brand new dungeon
experiences and ideas the way the
shrines and the divine beast were
structured required link to lose his
ability to climb walls which is
understandable since it would make it
too easy to get around a lot of puzzles
presented hence climate will service 'as
in these structures are limited to
grilles and ladders link is basically
set back to the restrictions of the
previous games which only allow climbing
on designated surfaces however there are
plenty of ways to traverse a dungeon
with the freeform climbing mechanic in
mind Nintendo can still restrict
climbing on specific surfaces by making
them slippery or knock you off by means
of electric tiles or spiked surfaces
certain puzzles can be solely based on
how you're going to reach a certain door
switch or platform but let's switch back
to the paraglider for a moment there are
a couple of shrines in breadth of the
wild that demonstrate how effective the
paraglider is at granting the player
never-before-seen options for dungeon
traversal I want to present to you the
potential of verticality in the past
dungeons have used the aspect of a
vertical space to shape a dungeons
layout but never before have we had
access to the type of mobility found in
breadth of the wild meaning the dungeons
can be vastly bigger and more impressive
which is one of breath of the wild
strong points even in the overworld just
the sheer magnitude and size of certain
landmarks alone can be overwhelming for
the most part platforming has been
reserved for the 2d installments the
auto jump in the 3d games takes away the
demand for precise jumping as you
we hold the control stick in the right
direction and you are good to go
the platforms are all spaced out so that
the jump will rarely fail and in the
words of Aaron Hanson why do I got a
leap across these platforms there's no
challenge here I hold the joystick up
just because the scenarios treacherous
doesn't mean the game is actually
treacherous and that is exactly why
breath of the wild 2 has a great
opportunity to introduce complex
platforming into the 3d games with
dungeons that require all sorts of crazy
stunts to parkour your way around here
are a couple of suggestions how about
jumping from wall to wall or climbing a
wall while obstacles are swaying back
and forth and you have to time your
jumps to avoid getting knocked off
climbing walls or blocks that move and
you have to cross from one to another at
the right time or better yet introduce
an item like the hookshot that allows
you to hook onto a wall while gliding
through the air cling to the walls or
prematurely release the chain to get an
extra speed boost to make your way
across an obstacle reminiscent of Just
Cause which combine paragliding with the
grappling hook to gain extra speed the
speaking of items dungeon items should
return in some shape or form one of the
most fun aspects of the traditional
dungeons in this series was the fact
that a significant portion of the
dungeon was inaccessible until you found
the dungeons main item in this regard
this item was basically functioning as
key to unlock new sections of the
dungeon and a great way to force
backtracking and making a mental note of
certain rooms you were not able to cross
previously breadth of the wild made
these options impossible by giving you
all the necessary tools at the very
start of the game not only that it
sabotages its own challenges because in
a lot of ways the player has an easier
way around a certain obstacle this
particular shrine called wind guides
located at the western border of the map
demonstrates the possibilities but also
the problems a sequel has to overcome
not only is this shrine bigger than most
other shrines but also shows how
verticality can be implemented in
breadth of the wild - you enter this
first room where you simply need to
activate this fan using a cork leaf
which you can actually get from this
chest right here next you enter this
area where you use the aforementioned
Corrick leaf to propel yourself to this
ledge
after which you see the sheikah monk but
are denied access by a locked door one
of only a few locked doors found in
of the wild following the path forward
presents you with this huge vertical
room which is traversed using all kinds
of different methods after playing
through so many small shrines this room
alone was a pleasant surprise
this also presents a problem however
you're supposed to fan an explosive
barrel across the gap to blow up these
stone blocks but if you happen to have
bomb arrows in your arsenal this puzzle
can be completely ignored and simply one
arrow will suffice to get the job done a
good example of how birth of the wilds
puzzles can be neglected by having the
right items in your stash you can ignore
certain fire based puzzles by having
fire based weapons I your disposal or
cheat these electricity puzzles by
dropping metal weapons and shields to
guide the current you get the point now
it is really cool how you can solve
puzzles in different ways something
that's actually rare in the Zelda
franchise usually there is only one
predetermined solution but it's much
preferred to outsmart a puzzle with
creative thinking rather than to
coincidentally carry an item that
destroys the purpose of the puzzle like
for instance in this shrine right here
where you're supposed to guide this
orbital on a path of drafts provided by
these fans
the idea is to rush to this block while
the orb gets guided along the path you
simply wait for the orb to reach the
pedestal and there you go but you can
simply place the orb right next to the
pedestal and use this metal box that is
meant to block a specific fans of the
orb crosses correctly to simply push the
orb in the pedestal from afar this is
off script but I actually solved it a
bit differently I place the orb down at
then used stasis ran to the block and
then just waited for the stasis to stop
these methods make you feel rather
clever by basically cheating the system
blue flame is another shrine that stands
out like wind guides it's a lot bigger
than most other shrines the central
mechanic behind this shrine is to
transfer this blue flame from section to
section the fact that the floor is lava
and you can't use a paraglider while
carrying the flame serves as a great way
to limit the player without a feeling
force all-in-all we think that some of
these ideas combined with new potential
mechanics that can be introduced in the
sequel could make breath of the wild to
dungeons work in many different ways
which brings us to the next point on the
list complexity and/or survival the
reason why there's
slash right here is because a dungeon
doesn't always have to meet both
criteria at the same time to succeed in
my book some are complex on a mechanical
level brainteaser if you will while
others derive their challenge from an
endurance round of combat and traps and
other obstacles that drain your hearts
with every step forward also known as a
gauntlet introduced by Mark Brown in his
boss key series yet others fall
somewhere in between in my opinion the
best sets of dungeons in the Zelda game
are the ones that mixes it up between
different styles a tangible comparison
would be the water temple versus the
shadow temple in ocarina of time the
shadow temple gets a lot of flack for
being painfully linear but I think that
was exactly the point
instead of getting lost and forcing you
to understand its architecture it's an
endurance round to the finish by the
time you reach the final stretch of the
dungeon you have descended deeper and
deeper into its inner structure you're
actively trying to stay alive since the
punishment is having to walk all the way
back to where you left off the water
temple is the complete opposite the
enemies and combat challenges are
nothing to write home about and if you
still manage to die then getting back to
the place where you left off doesn't
really take a whole lot of time instead
it's the complex structure it's many
floors different water levels and
interconnected rooms that drives the
challenge for breath the while to
presenting a gauntlet challenge isn't
too difficult especially if they
introduce some new and challenging enemy
types a dungeon like this would mostly
consist of narrow caves or corridors or
closed off rooms that just keep going
forward and forward rooms filled with
traps and enemies that provide a decent
challenge and you're good to go
even more so if progress is halted until
you defeat every last enemy in a room or
area something that was exceptionally
rare in breadth the wild as in most
cases you don't really have to fight
anything if you don't want to and can
just circumnavigate the enemies
altogether in terms of complexity
however there's plenty of options to
choose from and to a certain extent the
divine beasts as well as a small handful
of shrines already toyed around with
some great ideas I just wish they would
last a little bit longer the divine
beasts all incorporate the same general
idea of manipulating the dungeon itself
with your chica slate in my very first
playthrough once I entered the second
divine beast
it immediately dawned on me that this is
basically the same concept in the sequel
dungeon centered around this puzzle box
motif would be a lot more enjoyable if
they introduced a unique central
mechanic that doesn't revolve around the
same idea one of the aspects that made
dungeons in say Majora's Mask so
effective was the fact that each one had
a unique mechanic that requires an
understanding of how the dungeon works
before you are ready to progress by the
time you beat the second divine beasts
you already know what to expect from the
last to get the map manipulate sections
of the dungeon activated terminals fight
the boss it doesn't leave much room for
surprises next let's take a look at
aesthetics and atmosphere this part will
be a short one as it kind of speaks for
itself
the big turndown for both the divine
beasts and the shrines was the fact that
it didn't provide much variety don't get
us wrong the general idea of the orange
and blue technological vibe in the
shrines was kinda cool and as a
standalone dungeon it would have been a
great fit its kind of similar to the
temple of time in Twilight Princess a
very sterile and technological
atmosphere but after 120 iterations yeah
it starts to get old the same thing goes
for the divine beasts which all have
this brownish looking sheikah design the
music is slightly different in each one
but not by much it is really cool how
the music will ramp up with each
terminal you activate similar to Hyrule
Castle and Twilight Princess where the
music slowly gets more intense as you
progress however those fitting themes
found throughout the previous games are
greatly missed the haunting melody of
the forest temple the serene eastern
vibe of the ancient cistern and the
bizarre floaty theme in the city in the
sky from the very first 3d title every
dungeon had its own distinct look and
feel we don't necessarily need to go
back to the overused forest fire water
themes from before there are plenty of
other options to go with deep dark
caverns a dungeon based around
electricity and old abandoned ruin
filled with Indiana Jones esque traps or
a dungeon shaped like a huge tower that
is all about vertical movement where it
just keeps going up and up until you
reached a slight heights similar to the
Snowhead temple with this new engine
dungeons could be stretched to their
fullest potential a mix between the new
idea
from breath of the wild and the more
traditional 3d dungeons designed from
the older games with that in mind let's
take a look at something that definitely
changed from the older games namely
enemies and bosses when talking about
breath the wilds dungeons and mentioning
bosses and enemies we all know what I'm
about to say the dungeon bosses in
breath the wild were uninspired to say
the least they all share the same
aesthetics and generally felt like a
copy-paste designing including calamity
Ganon himself and I have to ask with a
game that has climbing as one of its
central mechanics why was this rarely
ever used in boss fights with the
exception of Stone Tallis to a very
small degree the fact that climbing was
not utilized further is a mystery to me
Shadow of the Colossus and God of War
set the perfect example in that regard
of course not every boss has to be
fought this way but come on when the
inclusion of climbing in breadth the
wild was first revealed in 2016 trailer
large and epic boss fights with climbing
involved was one of the first things I
imagined the sequel has a chance to
rectify this climbing could be used in
so many ways to battle a boss not just
climbing the body of the boss itself but
also your surroundings to get a vantage
point to hit it from above for example
all the while the boss could try to
knock you off with physical attacks or
projectiles forcing you to make time
jumps to avoid it now I can't say for
sure if we're gonna start with a fully
upgraded stamina wheel or if we're gonna
have to start from scratch but either
way not having enough stamina could
simply mean that you are not yet ready
to fight a specific boss until you
upgrade your stamina wheel which in
return encourages exploration to grow
stronger similar to a game like Dark
Souls where you won't even stand a
chance against a certain boss until you
level up first and again something like
a hook shot or a similar type of device
could be used in combination with
climbing and paragliding to latch on to
either the boss itself or an object like
a grill very reminiscent of a fight with
our garage in Twilight Princess but now
with a lot more mobility options the
closest we ever came to an actual aerial
boss battle was to fight with the curse
nhadra atop mount lanayru-- which now
that I think about it didn't even really
fight back huh not even sure if I would
classify
this as a boss battle but anyway an idea
like this could be expanded upon instead
of simply picking up some eye weak
points with arrows how about actually
having to land on the giant behemoth and
wailing on it that would be awesome
I'm pretty sure that Nintendo can come
up with some very unique looking
creatures and creative ways to fight
them as they have done so in the past
now that Lincoln climb and Glide bosses
can be bigger and more epic than ever
before oh and by the way mini bosses
would also make a welcome return as for
the rest of the dungeon enemies well
yeah the divine beast might as well have
not included them at all some guardian
Scouts here and they're flying curse
skulls and these eyeball things
definitely a huge step back from the
previous titles which all featured many
different enemy encounters and smart
enemy placement all around not only that
but in previous games each dungeon hosts
a set of enemies that are relevant to
its general theme undead and creepy
enemies mechanical enemies water-based
enemies and bats lots and lots of
fricking bats
nobody likes fighting these Nintendo in
any game so please don't
anyway let's wrap things up with the
final part of the list
size and scope the divine beasts didn't
exactly last very long and if a dungeon
is too short it undermines the
experience of course the same thing goes
the other way around if a dungeon is
Toulon and seems to drag on forever it
will eventually start to become
monotonous having a balanced dungeon
length is crucial a gigantic and
beautifully designed central room that
unlocks bit by bit for instance could be
amazing especially if combined with the
things we talked about in the previous
sections where you need to scale a
massive room solve puzzles to open
locked doors and challenging platform
sections involving the paraglider and
climbing if Nintendo indeed goes back to
more traditional dungeons I'm not too
worried that they would mess this part
up as judging by the track record they
have generally managed to make balanced
dungeons that were not over in a flash
but also didn't drag on too long just
keep in mind with breadth of the wild
size no longer poses the same problem a
massive room with sky high ceilings will
be much easier to traverse than it ever
in previous games it's more about how
long a dungeon is willing to go on for
before it starts to get stale just a
final stray thought I know a lot of work
went into the overworld of breadth the
wild as well as the physics and
chemistry engine I cannot even imagine
the amount of hours that went into
constructing this world and perfecting
the mechanics but now that all of this
exists and for a large part can be
reused it would be nice to have more
than just four main dungeons this time
around I don't want to sound demanding
but having the same amount of dungeons
as Majora's Mask a game that was
developed in just one year was kind of a
letdown for a game this ambitious and I
know breadth the wilds focus wasn't on
the dungeons this time around but rather
the overworld but now that we have
explored this landscape so extensively
it would be best if the overworld gets a
little bit more of a backseat this time
around you will still be able to roam
around and mined for materials do quests
and explore these beautiful locations
all that good stuff but have the main
focus be on something that lies beneath
the surface under the waters or maybe
even high up in the sky or on a remote
island somewhere this will also make
sure that the sequel will stand out
against this precursor something that is
always very hard for a direct sequel
either it turns out way too similar and
thus an original or strays away so far
from the original that it's
unrecognizable as a direct sequel and
that pretty much sums it up I want to
personally thank Nintendo black crisis
for joining me in this video I owe you
one
a link to his channel will of course be
in the description I will go into more
specifics in the near future as we
haven't even scratched the surface when
it comes to the possibilities look at
this as more of an introduction or
general idea of how a dungeon could be
constructed for the sequel
if breadth the wall to will for instance
bring back underwater swimming that
would already open up so many new
dungeon ideas if you made it all the way
through then you have just watched my
very first video and I thank you for
that I created this channel out of
passion for dungeon design and level
design in general however I will not shy
away from covering other topics in the
future and not only restricted to the
Zelda franchise and finally it's pretty
much youtube law to state this at the
end so here we go light
comment and subscribe until the next
video this is Don signing off and have a
good one okay now how do I stop reported